fewer people are going to college these
days and that's great news for decades
the percentage of recent high school
graduates attending college was climbing
until about 2008 when it started
leveling off
12 years later it went in the other
direction with the largest one-year drop
in over 30 years coming between 2019 and
2020 and then it continued falling into
2021. albeit at a lower rate
According to some analysts it's starting
to climb back up which would be a shame
The Wall Street Journal report said in
the past 10 years about 200 colleges
have closed down or four times as many
as in the previous decade meanwhile in
Tennessee where five colleges have
closed since 2016. officials have
launched a call to action to try to
reverse the trend number of Tennessee
students choosing to go to college his
slip the college going rate has dropped
about 10 percent over just the past five
years and the commission says in this
current economic reality a high school
diploma it just is not enough
State officials are promising new
programs to bring kids back to campus on
top of massive Federal subsidies for
colleges already on the books back in
2014 President Obama defended Federal
policies that encourage kids to go to
college in an interview with Tumblr
founder David carp who happens to be a
high school dropout Americans now hold
more than a trillion dollars in student
debt one of the greatest expenses
they'll incur in their lifetime
and the generation that's just reaching
College age is beginning to wonder if
it's even worth it some people are
wondering is this a good investment it
absolutely is
uh the difference between a
a college grad and somebody with a high
school diploma is about 28 000 a year in
income so it continues to be a very
smart investment for you to go to
college but Obama didn't explain the
reason for that wage premium which isn't
based on actual knowledge accrued by
college graduates as The Economist Brian
Kaplan argued in his 2018 book the case
against education most people don't
learn anything on campus that helps with
their actual jobs and only kids who make
it all the way to graduation earn more
that's because a college degree is
actually what Kaplan calls a signaling
mechanism or a way of showing that you
have the fortitude to make it through
employers want to hire college graduates
not because of what they learned in
English class but because they're more
likely to arrive on time and do what
they're told
once you accept that a lot of it is
about Yes master I will conform to what
our society demands of me that's where
graduation is so important that's why in
a country or College last three years
it's the third year that's crucial
countries in the last four years of the
fourth year that's crucial you know just
like in a country where suits are the
standard thing you were in interview you
better wear a suit or else you look like
a weirdo and people don't want to hire
you so why are fewer students going to
college now one theory is that employers
can't afford to care as much that
prospective employees can make it
through college because they're such a
big labor shortage that even high school
graduates are getting tantalizingly high
salaries for teenagers that may be
outweighing the draw of college
particularly with such eye-poppingly
high tuition rates Daniel Moody a 19
year old who took a job at a Ford
planned right out of high school told
the Associated Press that if I would
have gone to college after school I
would be dead broke the type of money
we're making out here you're not going
to be making that while you're trying to
go to college
another explanation for the decline of
college attendance is that a lot of
people my age are dropping out of the
workforce altogether okay that is a big
problem but sending more people to
college isn't going to solve it in 2020
about 75 percent of kids who took the
ACT did so badly that test
administrators deemed them unprepared
for college and yet over 60 percent of
high school graduates still go if we
could bring College attendance down even
more maybe fewer people would drop out
and be stuck with loans and no degree to
show for them there were a lot of us
with the pandemic we kind of had a
do-it-yourself kind of attitude of like
oh I can figure this out a high school
graduate in Tennessee named Grayson Hart
told the Associated Press like many
teens hurt thinks the time and money
spent on College could be used more
productively by just starting his career
why do I want to put in all the money to
get a piece of paper that really isn't
going to help with what I'm doing right
now said Hart who's directing a youth
theater program
I hope more high school students ask
themselves that question